when I had the gyms I materially looked
successful because we had six locations
but I always just put all my money back
into each new location so I had very
little actual cash I was asset rich in
Cash 4 but then when I lost everything I
was like wait because I had nothing to
show for it and so that's probably what
has created a lot of the hypothesis I
have now around I didn't lose the five
years I lost the assets which were not
the most valuable thing that I had
earned over that time it was the skills
the experiences the character traits
because I still had those and then using
those three things I was able to do the
next thing fortunately